The joe rogan experience,
an honor to be here.
A pleasure and honor to have you,
sir.
Brian is my longest running
friend in Hollywood.
I think so,
right?
Yeah,
for sure.
Any years?
Yeah.
We've been friends a long ass time.
Almost 20 years.
Yeah,
94 or something like that.
People still come up to me.
It was 90 1995 and people still come up
to me and ask me if we're half brothers.
You are the ones that who's
used to say it on Wikipedia.
That's right.
I am DB one of those.
It's a rumor.
I like keeping a lot.
I keep it alive.
I don't,
I never refuted it either.
Do I now?
Now I think you were the one who
told me about Gracie Jujitsu.
Yeah,
I remember that.
I remember we connected immediately.
Yeah.
You show up in those guys are all just
low blood sugar and just a bunch of
actors.
All of a sudden this guy,
see,
I'm like,
wait a minute,
that guy looks like me,
but he's thicker and then he looks way
more extreme and you had a tank top on
and you were like,
can possibly muster.
I was like,
that guy looks like he
fights and you're like,
yeah,
if I like to fight,
I need to fight.
I didn't do I need to be in class,
otherwise I will end up in jail.
And I was like,
that guy's going to be my friend forever.
We connected so quick
right away with everything,
every retarded thing.
We'd love pit bulls and,
and,
and we're,
we both know it's retarded.
That's the difference.
Like all of my extreme macho psycho shit.
I know it's fucked up.
Like I know my tattoos are fucked up.
I know my neck is too big.
I don't give a fuck,
you know,
I know my car is too loud.
I don't care.
You won't like it.
You've always been my,
my canary in the coal mine.
You as well.
You know,
as long as I know you're
still out there alive,
someone's rocking it the right way.
No doubt.
You're crazy to think that you would ever
want to do anything different because
whatever you've done has made you,
you,
you know,
I,
I'm sorry for anybody that
ever hurt their feelings,
but I'm so happy.
Everything turned out the
weird turning against you,
right?
Man,
I never thought of that.
I really liked that.
As I was thinking of as a,
as you were talking,
I went,
I spent a lot of time
wishing I was somebody else.
That's why I'm an accurate,
that's why I'm a comic.
And by the way,
that is who I am,
isn't it?
We don't want a guy who wishes he was,
who spends a lot of time
wishing he was somebody else.
That's my identity.
Every guy wants an undefeated record.
Okay,
but I'm telling you,
that shit ain't good for you.
You have to understand
what it's like to lose.
Of course,
you have to understand failure.
You have to,
you have to be able to look back in
your past at a moment where you fuck
something up and feel uncomfortable about
it and that should provide you with a
certain amount of humility and they're
just trying to understand that.
I think a man is,
is the product of what partially a large
but largely a product product of of how
of the actions he chose to
take as a response to failure.
You know?
Yeah,
for sure.
I don't know how you learn
anything other than the hard way.
I don't,
I mean you don't really,
you don't really look where
we're a strange animal
that's dealing with infinite
variables and the only way to truly find
a focused way through this path is to
have accumulated a massive
amount of experiences and
forged positive information
and game plans from these experiences
and be able to move forward.
You cannot know it all
right away from the get go.
That's all you can do is control how you,
how you respond to failure,
what you choose to do differently
or readjusting your approach.
And by the way though,
the one thing for me is
I've learned just to enjoy,
enjoy that and allow the frustration,
uh,
you be able to make fun
of yourself when you fuck.
You guys can do that.
So huge.
There was a guy that's some big,
so big and then you're great at it.
There was a guy recently,
I say recently,
it was in within the last couple of years.
It was back when,
uh,
legends was at the,
the old bomb squad on Santa Monica
Boulevard where the two Jimmys.
Yeah.
Anyway,
this guy picked up a hooker.
He came back from Iraq,
picked up a hooker,
turns out the hooker was a dude
the had sucked this deck for,
I don't think I was a guy,
shot him,
no.
Dumped the body in an
alleyway and an alley way,
like a movie.
So the cops apparently see
this guy dumped the body,
the high speed,
chase and sues.
They chased him all the
way up to the desert,
gets out of the car with
his gun suicide by cop.
They shoot him dish.
And all I'm thinking of
is this motherfucker,
if he could just make fun of himself,
would have the best story ever.
So true.
The idea of the stubble and this
guy did it really quiet suddenly.
You don't know that story?
No.
Interesting.
Well,
if I may,
if you'll please leave.
I've never told you this story.
I can't believe you haven't either.
And you might have.
I met,
I'm at Club USA.
Yay.
In,
uh,
New York City.
How many years ago?
Oh,
I dunno.
20.
I know.
I'm,
I'm 63 now.
I just had a lot of work done,
but um,
uh,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm a Ahmed USA.
I'm a young man and a,
I'm dancing and,
uh,
with my buddy and I meet this,
I have a weakness for Latina girls,
right?
Little petite,
curvy.
I see this beautiful Latino girl.
She's got this black pony tail.
She's got,
she's got that caramel skin,
this cute little ass I know.
And this title,
stop touching.
She's dead.
She's dancing,
she's dancing.
She's,
I'll start,
he said,
stop.
Sorry.
She's dancing and she's dancing and she
locks eyes with me with the eyes of a
fighter.
I mean,
just looking at me and I'm like,
all right,
well there's,
that's my wife.
That's my wife right there.
I start dancing with her and we're aligned
and we're dancing and she smells like
fucking apricots.
I don't remember what it smells like.
We're for the story.
She smells like fucking apricots.
And I'm just this,
we started making out and I mean Bob
slapping on the dance floor and you know,
sometimes when you're that attracted,
everything else melts away.
You just see that one person.
I'm a little drunk and I'm
kissing her and it's romantic.
I mean deep.
Oh God.
So there are these booths,
there were these peak booths at Club USA
where you could go in and there was a
glass thing where other
people can watch you.
So I take this girl into the Pete booths
and I didn't give a fuck [inaudible]
glass.
So other people can watch and
you want to come into the booth?
They can watch.
But no freaking,
I was 20 I was 23 I didn't give a fuck.
I was like,
I'll take my,
I'll fucking fucking right here.
I didn't condom shut off.
So I'm literally like,
I'm going to fuck this girl
right here in this club and say,
you cuff me.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I was just in love.
I'm going to get hurt.
This is my girlfriend.
This is about as my girlfriend forever,
so I'm kissing and I'm making
out and I'm feeling a body.
He's got his little dance.
I'm like,
these are small.
It doesn't matter.
Our waste so hard enough for
the ask was on another level.
Yeah.
She had a beautiful ass and
I reached down and I go for,
well I grab a grab a branch,
I grab a fucking branch that
had been talked under and she,
he goes up and pulls my hand away and
I immediately realize that was a cop.
I've been,
I've been deep kissing,
deep kissing for two hours,
so I'm definitely a little gay.
I mean deep kissing and
I just grabbed a cock.
You ever thought it did not
know about the cock and tight?
How did I not know,
dude?
Because she was,
she was taking hormones obviously.
Secondly,
she was already like had that skin,
Latino or Filipino,
whatever she was,
where she just didn't
have hair on her body.
She was petite.
He,
I keep saying she sees
such a girl and you know,
but here's this here at ready.
Here's the,
here's why I'm a good guy.
Here's what I have a
really fucking nice guy.
Nope.
I,
I looked in her eyes.
She was so hurt his eyes.
He was so like,
he was just like,
please let this big and
I'm such a fucking onstar.
I felt so bad that I go,
I go back in to kiss her.
I kiss her him for
another like two seconds,
three seconds.
When I go on the lips,
of course food.
You fuckers now listen.
Oh,
I'm not
go.
I go like this.
I go,
oh.
oh fuck.
I have an old sir.
I have an ulcer in.
My stomach is killing me.
And she goes,
you do?
I go,
yes.
She goes,
do you have to go to the bathroom?
I go,
no,
no.
I just have to.
I have a very bad old sir.
Sometimes it just keeps,
so I want to protect her feelings.
I felt bad.
Him,
his shit,
his ass.
That's how I got out
and I left and I never,
I did not come back to that quote.
I can't believe you went
back in and you got to be,
I didn't want to be rude.
No.
Wait a minute.
We've been the person,
some person pretended to be a girl
and tricked you into kissing him.
Never even told you something.
That for a lot of guys
would make them violent.
I would a gay band for a lot of guys.
What'd you relive?
I would've been mad if that,
if this person [inaudible] guys,
it's an experience.
Well,
okay for you,
but for a lot of guys,
it's an experience that they don't want
to have and someone tricked them into
doing it and they could
get violent and I don't,
I don't justify it,
but I'm saying a lot of guys,
that would be the reaction.
The fact that you felt bad.
It's very strange.
And he went back and then,
and then what?
Or a poem did you have
a of ton after that?
Uh,
I don't believe a kissed with Tom,
but if I tell the story again,
I'll definitely use that.
Isn't it funny how Lego a
memory from that far back?
It's almost bullshit anyway,
cause it's so like fragmented and odd.
It's like I can recite the facts
of a lot of details of my life,
but do it truly recall them.
And if I didn't have a language,
they wouldn't even exist to my memory
banks to tell you another story.
Please do this.
Did I tell you that Jimmy Burke story?
Which one?
A midnight?
No,
a million Jimmy Burke stories.
The one where where we were both
together with two girls on a bed.
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
All right.
That's good.
Okay.
So I had my best friend's thumb in my ass.
All right.
Uh,
but that's a whole different story.
Joe.
What you put your thumb.
Oh,
what should I tell?
Did I tell him,
sign my thumb?
Let's be clear about because we refer
to each other as best friends and I tell
him my thumb was never anywhere
near the punchline away,
but there's a very,
very good excuse for it.
No wonder why it's not on the podcast.
Well,
should I tell him the podcast,
it's a little late because
you already gave away.
The punchline is if you can tell
the story somehow or another make it
entertaining even though
the punchline is already,
I used to have ice date,
I two girlfriends for a long time that
I had sex with 10 years after the fact.
They were just my two girls.
Loved them,
loved them.
I had touched with those girls.
I,
you know that we dated in
college and then I dated him.
We want to add right after college
and and for the next 10 years,
maybe longer.
They were always a booty
call and I was kind of,
relationships are so strange,
so weird.
Even through their boyfriends to
girlfriends and we would always get crazy.
Paul,
how many,
how many girls like that have a guy like
that somewhere in their life where they
just have some arrangements
and they can always up places.
Right.
I know.
Dirty.
How can you tell what,
what do you most of all?
And because they're there,
they talk about him a lot because he's
still in their life because he's still
really important to them
because they had a long time.
I can always tell him,
you're saying you could sniff
it if a girl's doing it to you,
you can tell.
I mean,
I know.
And it just gives you like
a nice green light though.
You're like,
okay,
yeah,
yeah.
You should be friends.
You should be automatically goes,
can assume that she's
doing that just horr ramp.
I was that,
I was that with this one girl.
Right.
Sorry about the training,
but I was that with this one girl and she,
um,
hold on one second.
It's,
it's getting hot in here.
I'm going to turn the AC on.
Continue the story.
I'm sorry for,
I'll go slower Joe.
So,
so,
so she um,
she basically was a,
uh,
she,
she was the girl,
both of them were,
you know,
my girls for a long time.
They are down at a restaurant
in New York City called Il Buco,
which is a great restaurant by the way.
And I get a call from one of them,
which is essentially like,
Hey Brian,
it's,
it's such and such and such and such
and we're hanging out and we really wish
you were here.
And we were talking about
you and we were talking,
telling dirty stories,
whatever they were saying.
And I,
I couldn't call back fast and I was like,
where are you?
Like where ideal Buco I'm like,
I'll be there.
I'll be there now.
I mean I was literally like 20 minutes
away and I got down there in five
minutes.
I would say I was at
his hand at the capitol.
I drive taught that I get there.
Long story short,
because I'm a team player,
I call my best friend Jimmy Burke.
That's it.
I called Jimmy Burke.
I say,
get down here.
That by the way is
always the code for fuck.
And there's something about to go
down and it always involves pussy.
Get down here he goes,
be right there guy.
He's there in two seconds,
we'll drink and wine.
I'm fucking getting them all
applied up talking about it.
I could see the two of them,
the two girls are,
are,
are all over each other.
And I'm like,
Oh,
you want to use me as a bridge to
have an experience with each other.
How interesting.
My two old girlfriends who subsequently
asked me to have children with them,
by the way,
just to use my sperm,
which was very flattering,
but I had to say no.
But anyway,
so,
okay,
so I'm like that Jimmy Burke goes,
hey guys,
let's go back to my,
I call him the maestro.
He,
he goes,
let's go back to my place.
Let's go back to my place.
I'll pull the fire,
got some weed,
I'll make some fucking
chocolate chip cookies.
How's that sound?
We'd fireplace chocolates or cookies.
They're like,
uh,
yeah.
Okay.
Sounds good.
We get to the place.
Uh,
he goes to the kitchen to get,
like,
to start whipping up
chocolate chip cookies.
He's bringing out some weed.
He goes to the kids,
we bring,
who brings out we'd,
it brings out a joint.
By that time,
I'm already naked on the bed with the,
with the girls.
I'm already naked.
And he's like,
what the fuck is,
this is a locking block though.
He is.
And I'm like,
oh my God,
you no longer look at my boss.
I'm like,
oh my look at you.
I'm like looking at him.
I go,
I go to Jamaica.
I'd rather be nowhere else
in the world right now,
Bro.
This is the place to be.
This is the greatest
experience of my life.
Literally like I'm living a
porn right now and I love them.
They're both my girls.
So Jimmy's lived,
oh,
let me take my clothes off.
He takes it.
He looks like a red,
bumpy pickled,
by the way.
He's fucking hairless.
Got a piece on him and I'm like,
that's just not attractive to me.
But whatever.
So he's trying to get
this girl's pants down.
He's getting and he's trying to,
and he's got a tongue
literally that goes literally,
he could catch fucking flies.
He's like one of those frogs.
He's taken this girl's pants down.
He's trying to get his
taste frog tongue in there.
She's cheese trying to
go down the other girl.
So she's more than the other
girl as I'll make no young gun.
I'm like,
Oh,
is that my car glare?
As you know,
I'm just a fucking,
I'm sorry to be this graphic,
but the point is,
it was just a fucking fucking business.
So,
so he,
he's trying to get us
done and she stopped.
She goes,
wait,
hold on.
I don't like this.
You guys need to,
you guys need to get
do something together.
I,
I don't,
I don't like to say I
look at Jim and we'd go,
oh,
we don't do that.
I don't do that.
See,
I don't fuck around with guys
because it's not that I'm homophobic.
I'm just not attracted to the guys.
And I definitely have a hard on right now.
And so it was my buddy
and there's no fucking,
it's best bad enough.
We're about two feet away from each other.
I'm not doing anything with my buddy.
And this is the girl that
Jimmy was trying to eat out,
right?
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
Like in Jimmy,
right.
She was more into the girl she was into,
you know,
so,
um,
so she says,
so she says to Jimmy and
Jimmy could give a fuck.
He,
he,
he doesn't give a shit.
He's down to go.
And if he has to fuck me
in the ass to get to this,
he's gonna,
he's like this.
I can see the look in his
eyes and he's fucking like,
let's go.
Let's go.
What the fuck do you need me to do?
I want you guys to make out
that we had done a play,
not a sketch where we,
where we make as a joke.
And I go,
no,
no.
I don't make out with guys.
It's disgusting.
Can't do it.
I can't do it.
I had to do it.
I think there was a part,
there was a,
you said you wrote a plate
that you guys are good.
I wrote this play as we can make out.
I can't,
I can't make out what there is.
But I did write this play where I make
out with can every letter and it's
unfortunate that it had to be that way,
but I had to make out with a guy.
But that's what I wrote,
that it's what I wrote.
It's called kissing up boy.
But the point is this
is what my Dick Hard,
right?
Why am I crying?
Why?
Okay,
why am I crying your wise anyway,
so,
uh,
so before I can even do it,
Jimmy goes,
I'll fucking kiss him egos.
Get over here.
You fucking pussy.
He goes like,
pulls me away cause you happy.
She goes,
yeah,
it goes down.
And I'm like that.
So now I'm back to my girl,
I'm back to my girl and we're,
well we're locked in and we're making
out and all of a sudden I feel the other
girls,
I feel the other girl's ass hand
around my ass cause he felt good.
Brian.
I'm like,
it feels fucking good.
All of a sudden they feel like I'm not a,
I'm not an ass play guy
to be honest with you.
But I feel like finger going and my mom,
my mug with,
so if you will,
if I can general chip,
you show I'm going to
a mug wish and look at,
I've got a sewer pickle up there,
you know what I mean?
So I'm like,
ah,
okay.
That,
oh,
the book.
She goes,
I feel good.
I go,
oh,
I guess so you're a girl.
I wouldn't go,
well,
you know it went in Rome.
I'm like,
AH,
fuck off.
And I'm just sewing and this guy and then,
and then I,
then I feel what feels like
a greyhound bus in my ass.
You understand a greyhound
bus in my ass to which I go,
oh,
like that.
Exactly what I went,
oh like that.
And I turn around like this.
I'm stuck.
I all,
I can do it.
My back,
I turned,
I go,
oh,
I like that.
And my buddy's got his thumb and
my ass and he goes like this.
He goes,
you fucking pussy.
Oh,
now let me explain.
Let me explain.
Let me explain why and
how she said to him,
I'm not going to do any more.
I will fuck you,
but you have to stick
your finger in his ass.
Do you don't have the
balls and Jimmy goes,
what?
I don't have a fuck.
Fuck you shut the fuck.
Yay.
I like that.
Like she gives a shit,
right?
Like,
Hey guy,
I mean a little something here.
I understand wanting to get laid,
but the stick your
finger in my fucking ass.
I go,
here's the problem.
I've got to tell us otherwise we're gay.
I told everyone in the world,
he sold a half a million
people on the podcast.
Hey,
you know what?
There it is.
I told,
I told my friends in New York,
we told the story.
They went like this.
My buddy like Jared McFadden,
they,
they had their hands in their pocket.
They listen.
They just went,
fuck this,
turn around and walk the
talk to me,
shaking their head in a bad mood.
I was like,
Hey,
can I fly in Jimmy out here?
Yes.
The next time you do the podcast,
let's schedule it in like
three or four weeks from now,
somewhere before thanksgiving.
I love it.
You come out to do the podcast,
we'll fly Jimmy out from
New York if he can do it.
But by the way,
Jimmy and I had so much fun in New York.
I was just thinking about how we used
to pick up girls by posing as doctors.
Remember that?
Oh Dude.
Sitting there drinking all your lines.
I said,
oh,
so he lives,
he saved.
Oh,
so you do like I'm a doctor and yeah,
but we'd set up like this.
A lot of times we set out like this,
you,
me and my buddy and Jimmy be over there
drinking a beer at the end of the bar.
It's worked fucking every time.
Every time.
And you know,
we'd be in there like a couple of years.
We find really hot girls.
I come up and go,
excuse me,
sorry to bother you.
Girls were doctors and my buddy just said,
and he's a great surgeon,
but he just lost his first patient.
He's really bummed out if you guys went
over there and just talk to them and
make them see it and feel so much better.
And they'd be like,
he's a surgeon.
They're like,
yeah,
we're all surgeons and
if you talk to a girl,
and she was actually a doctor.
Well,
how about the girl was asking you
a medical advice and you felt bad.
You had to come clean.
I felt horrible.
Hey,
she's asking him and medical advice
and he starts giving her like general
advice,
not me,
man.
I mean,
I fucking stuck to the end and I was like,
I'm getting laid.
I don't give you shit.
Back to makeup.
Showed the line while
your plasma rich plates.
I just invent shit.
I was a fucking idiot.
You then 30 30 30 a grown man.
That's how old I was.
Then we pretend we'd,
then we'd recognize each
other like I come up and go.
I like,
we'd sit right next to the hottest
girls in the club or something.
I'd go,
Dude,
you've got to just tell you,
I saw your movie at Sundance.
You're in fucking [inaudible].
You are.
You're doing dineros in
your next little bit,
right?
Yeah.
Well actually he's directing it.
Oh fuck.
Congratulations on such an amazing actor.
Bryan County.
I had a film there too.
I don't know if you saw it,
Leland,
what's the name of the fucking thing?
Dude,
it worked every time because
they remodel actresses.
They're like,
hey,
you know I,
and I'd go like this.
I go,
I'm sorry these girls with you,
can I buy you guys a drink?
And they like,
actually I was brilliant.
That's so simple.
Right in,
we were talking,
it never fail.
When you a normal looking guy,
you got to fucking use your mind
and you've got to be a higher,
higher tending to be
famous and getting that,
oh this is an important use grace and
we out of fight suit glocal Jimmy Burke.
We have to do that anymore.
Chicks,
you just Google your name.
Did we up there fucking
giant android screen and go?
Yeah.
It doesn't say shit about you.
How about telling how bad of a
fucking movie at Sundance and liar.
It is weird singing.
You hang out with different people though.
Cause it seems like certain
people you act different,
you know,
like you're more silly.
Or when you're with the league,
I mean I'm a chameleon mean like
my sister who calls me a chameleon,
you know what my buddy happening,
Tampax has said about me.
He goes,
you know Brian Walks,
if Brian walks,
it takes a walk with
seven Cherokees when he,
well you know what comes back a Cherokees.
It's like ah fuck.
It's true that I had to be that way.
It's a kid I had to plan in when I moved.
Moved here is very unique.
I mean it's not like,
you know,
you're,
you're very unique.
Bullshit.
I try to be short bus unique
either your your unique dude.
But yeah,
you and I always wind up with caveman
conversations that I always go fucking
right to the bottom of a man's soul
to what we think about violence and
sexuality and you know,
all this fucking societies and illusion
and what happens when it crumbles down,
that fucking guy is going to fall apart.
But that's what I hear.
You and I have always had this
friendship where like where,
no matter what,
if we're lying to each other,
like if we're just,
we're like,
if we just don't want to deal
with the truth right now,
we'll just start saying something like,
and like I would be like,
I really love her.
And he'd be like,
Hey,
who are you fucking talking to now?
You're down.
I'm like,
but I live with her.
Yeah.
So what,
you don't love her break
up with her immediately.
You know,
I could never get away.
We can never really get away
with like lying to each other.
You know,
you were just too good of a friend to
have these crazy girls who were there.
And when I say crazy girls put folks,
I'm not an invasive sort of a a
friend when it comes to friends,
girlfriends,
like Brian can tell you I'm,
I'm usually a pretty supportive,
right when you say Brian Korea.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And I did it a lot of crazy girls
and he stayed a lot of crazy girls.
No Fun.
But my take on it was always
just be sweet to them,
be nice to him,
fuck the shit out of them.
And if they leave,
they leave.
Right.
You know that's how you go.
But with you,
you had a totally different kind of
crazy and developed an addiction.
You had a fascination with girls
who were gigantic problems.
Yeah.
Brian's girls are sweet girls.
They just,
what happens in life?
You'd take a left when he should,
should've taken a ride.
You get stuck.
You can't pay your rent.
There's a lot of shit that
happens to people in life.
So he's dealing with essentially
sweet girls that go down a bad track.
Your dealing with fucking crazy people
where you can lose your fucking house.
Oh,
not just lose your house,
your life,
your life.
You had,
he had a few of them,
man,
where he would bring over like it was,
it was like Joe Lewis,
his bum of the month club,
who's great,
bring over all these new silly
bitches that he was dating.
One of them I called bunch of naps.
How she read it.
She came over.
I met her cookies.
Yeah.
She comes over and I go,
they check neat.
It looks like she needs a bunch of naps.
Right.
And then 10 minutes into
hanging out at my house,
Oh my God,
I'm so tired.
She takes her shoes off
and curls up on the couch,
was a fucking cash.
I literally,
she was like,
having owning a high tech
patch was so string love.
She's my pet.
It was so strange.
I have never met like,
uh,
more cat,
like human rights.
I've never met a person who just like
had no desire to have an intelligent
conversation,
just wanted to take naps.
I talked to this guy and this,
this fucking,
I talked to this awesome dude who's a,
who's a well known,
um,
like uh,
uh,
like a,
a psychiatrist's his phd.
He's really smart guy.
And he said a lot of times
people in relationships,
like he works with a lot of like
couples and stuff like that.
And then addicts and stuff.
He said,
and he said,
a lot of times what human beings do
is we apply a construct on someone.
So they'll,
you'll find somebody that looks the part
and then you just apply a construct.
You just go,
oh,
that's who you are.
You're this girl.
You really like to work out.
Yeah.
You're the j crew girl on,
on,
on a fucking,
on the front of a sail boat.
That's what I want to date me.
While the girl was like,
I'm from fucking Michigan,
I never been on a sample of my fucking
life and I like to do drugs every day.
What are you talking about?
No,
you know,
why were you trying to construct the,
that's sort of a,
a really non realistic
reality though all the time.
I don't know,
because it wasn't like,
it was really strange.
It's like that's the kind of behavior
that you get from people that have a hard
time meeting girls.
But you had no problem eating girls.
It wasn't that at all.
You were not shy.
You're always charming
and you're always funny.
So I mean,
I can't remember a time where you're like,
dude,
I can't meet girls.
And just tired of being alone.
It was never that.
It was,
it was you,
you know,
for whatever reason would wind up getting,
I can't crazy girl like this.
There were so nuts,
dude,
that I was trying to figure out.
I spent many an hour by myself thinking
about you after many of our crazy
adventures,
thinking about you going,
how did this happen?
How did this guy get to this state of
mind where he lets this person in his life
and then he can't see that.
I don't understand that.
This is what I'm hanging out with you.
I'm like,
here's this insightful,
intelligent,
objective self deprecating guy who's
really well read and yet he's hanging
around with legit methods.
You were hanging around with like
scary people there were like,
no,
I really don't know what that was.
I think part of it was just,
um,
I think what it was was I'd go,
oh,
that's a project and I
can save that person.
Yeah.
I think that was a lot of them.
That was,
I found that very
intriguing where I'd say,
you know what?
All you need is someone like me to change
your life and I know how to help you.
And it took me a long time to realize
that that is the dumbest shit you can
advocate for it.
Anybody dead fucking end or you never
want to do that shit like goodness.
It is.
You know you never want to
do that because you can't.
You know,
my father said something
interesting to me the other day.
He said,
look,
you want to give advice to a kid?
Very different.
Don't ever get advice ever,
ever to an adult,
even if even if that can use it.
I'm never doing it.
I said,
yeah,
but I the guys,
he's headed toward a wall.
He goes,
that's right.
And they know their head into a wall.
This is your dad.
Yeah.
And he said,
you're your do a talk show.
I got to get them on online.
Yeah.
You get him on the pot.
Because one of my favorite
people in the world,
this the greatest,
does he live here?
He's in a month.
Why don't you get it?
Can I say,
can I go on with your dad?
Oh,
that'd be great.
Leaves.
Well,
he's a great guy to
talk to about politics,
about the state of the fucking world.
I would love about everything because
he's living in a hundred countries.
Oh Jesus.
He's going to Italy right now just
to brush up on his Italian and my,
why are you doing it?
He goes,
I dunno.
I'm going to Rome for three weeks.
Wow.
He,
he was the greatest.
He said a sock and he was like,
uh.
We were talking about like having a,
you know when,
when you're with a woman you want to be
able to talk to her and sometimes you
can,
he goes talk to her.
What would you want to talk to her?
I've been married to
your mother for 50 years.
I want to talk to her and I'm not going.
It's ridiculous.
You've got to work.
You've got to fucking work.
My stupid,
it was so great.
He's such a bottom,
bottom line guy and has read everything,
but it's also just a real man,
you know,
a real,
a real flood.
Sounds like a fun guy to talk to him.
He's more of those.
I call them every day when I needed it.
When I,
when I want to talk about
something in the news or saw,
talk about just crazy with them.
How deep do you go in the rabbit hole?
As deep as it gets.
Really,
you're that guy where you can go all
the way into the rabbit hole with him.
Like personal secrets.
Fuck yes.
Anything.
And be careful by the way,
cause he'll fucking,
he'll,
he'll smell you.
He'll smell.
You're like,
oh my God.
Smell.
Yeah.
How about this?
I'll give you a great story.
Ready?
Watch this.
My buddy comes in,
I swear to God,
I'm with my dad,
we're in my office.
My buddy comes in,
he just happened to be
around cause he was gonna,
you know,
he just comes in and goes,
Hey Brian,
how are you doing?
I go,
Hey,
you know,
let's say his name is Jeff.
Hey Jeff,
what's up?
And he goes,
no,
I'm gonna tell you doing.
I go,
I'm good.
And he goes,
all right man,
I love this question because
there's a couple of words.
And he goes,
Hey,
Ms. Guy doing nice to meet you.
Yay.
And he just leaves.
And My,
my father,
my father goes,
what's that guy do?
And I go,
oh,
he's,
he's a writer.
My father said,
oh,
I suspect that's not
going to work out for him.
And I go and I go,
how did you know that?
Then he goes,
pattern recognition.
I've been around,
I'm 71 years old.
That's how pattern rather
than Russian mission.
So he's like that guy from the Bill
Ben Stiller movie where he has like the
human lie detector on it.
That's what he can read
you in a heartbeat,
dude.
He can read,
he can see you walk across the street.
He knows your whole fucking life.
Then again,
how the fuck are you so bad at that?
Well,
I'm actually good at it.
I choose to ignore it.
Really?
Yes,
I did actually.
I think I'm very good at it,
but when I see a project I go,
hey,
I need to help you.
So you almost,
well,
there was a self
destructive aspect to you.
Uh,
the,
the always disturbed me being your friend.
That's what would drive me nuts,
you know?
And it was a distraction and it drives me.
It hurt my career by the way.
Really?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It hurt my career and it
hurt my relationships with
people that were significant
in my life and yeah.
Um,
and I think a lot of that self sabotage,
we all go through that stuff.
You go through it,
man,
you will weigh less than,
than anybody.
I knew actually you were always very
good at cutting out the fat and I kept it
because I wanted an excuse maybe to,
uh,
you know,
I mean it was like a parachute.
You know what I mean?
I think,
um,
there's very few reasons in life to give
yourself more problems and if you can
find all your own problems and address
them and try to deal with all your own
problems and be real honest about that,
then it makes it really easy
to see other people's problems.
But I've found that in my life when I
wasn't being honest with myself about my
own problems,
when I had issues,
when I had unresolved things in my mind,
just went,
it was a real young man.
I was still growing up and trying
to get over my fucked up childhood.
I found it much more difficult for me to
see problems in other people because of
the,
the shield that I put on
recognizing my own issues.
I wasn't as intuitive or insightful when
it came to recognizing other people.
As I get older and I became as
honest as is humanly possible,
which is how I am now,
um,
now,
then it became where I
just see it everywhere.
That became really obvious.
That's what I have now become obsessed
with and that's why I don't suffer fools
anymore.
Like that's why,
because what I'm,
what I'm very interested
in is figuring out,
I want to stay as undiluted as I can
and as authentic when I was watching
Springsteen,
but I,
the word that kept popping into
my head was just authentic.
He's never lying.
It's everything about him,
the way he dresses,
the way everything about it
and nothing is in his way.
There's no resistance is why you can do
a back bend and touch his head at 62.
Why,
why?
He could literally back Ben,
he went all the way back and hit his head.
He can,
he can run.
He's 62.
That's amazing.
On stage,
on stage,
on lot back then at 62.
And I went and I went,
that guy is so out of his own way.
You know,
I've said this before,
maybe on the podcast,
but it's one of my favorite metaphors
that Michelangelo said when he was Clark.
He says name.
I mean when,
when we got last week,
I'm sorry guys,
I speak Thai.
Uh,
sorry.
There are no girls here.
Okay,
sorry.
Sorry.
When Michelangelo,
uh,
said,
when he carved the David The statue of
David and he had this piece of marble and
he said,
and this is a great metaphor for art,
it's already in there.
I just had to get all
this shit out of the way.
And he said,
that's how you should look
at yourself as a human being.
You're born and you acquire
a lot of shit as you're,
as you're growing up,
right?
So as you grow up,
a lot of Shit's put on you,
uh,
your family,
how they define you,
what they,
what they do to you.
Uh,
PA school,
high school,
the trauma of school,
the grief you go through,
you know,
your body is and what you wanted to do,
those losses and stuff and
you put on a lot of stuff,
you,
you come to the world when you're ready
to take it on at 30 with a whole lot of
fucking baggage.
And a lot of it's negative,
you know,
and the,
the job then is to figure out a
way to get that stuff off you,
to shed that stuff and get
back to who you really are,
the authentic you.
And that to me is at least as a comic
and as somebody who writes and stuff,
that's,
that's all I think about now.
You know,
what is,
what is how honest can I
truly be with my expression,
even if I'm being silly and like
talking about saving a whale,
there's a lot of me in there that I'm,
I'm talking about,
you know,
and especially now the stuff
that I'm working on now,
just,
you know,
being a father and things like that and
that responsibility and what that really
means and,
and,
uh,
with my daughter and,
and not being able to
show up her a part of me,
uh,
and,
and who,
who I want,
she's gonna model the men.
She dates after me,
so I gotta be a fucking,
I got to be the,
I gotta be her hero.
I got to be the guy that she actually,
I don't want to Dayton
the guy I used to be,
you know what I mean?
So there's all those responsibilities
that you start taking on as you get older.
But so much of that is,
and so much of fucking thought,
you know,
but I've got to think,
they act like it's an active process.
Thinking and being creative is actually
learning what not to think about because
the rest of it comes to it.
There's the dead.
That's a,
that's a real philosophy.
If you can open yourself up and think of
thinking as being more of a channel for
what's available to you,
that that's a very important distinction.
This notion that,
that see a lot of people come and say,
well,
I'm missing something.
I'm missing something that
I have to add to my arsenal.
No.
In fact,
what you're probably doing is there's,
there's something you've got to let
go of and when you let go of that,
you'll get what you're looking for
or you'll find that that that's a,
that's a fundamental difference
in thinking about thing.
And I think a lot of times we're taught,
hey,
you,
you're missing something.
You got to add to your year.
You got to put another
Arrow in your quiver.
In fact,
you might have the,
the,
the uh,
better,
better advice may maybe to say,
you got to let some stuff go,
man.
You're holding on to some stuff.
You've got to let some stuff go.
You're still defining yourself along
lines that are not helpful to you.
You're still,
you still have people in your
life that are not your friends,
even though they seem like they are,
you still have,
you're still doing a job that you
hate because it's an excuse to not do,
not go for what you really want.
There are a lot of things
that you should be deleting.
You should be taking out of your life and,
and,
and then there will be room for
something that's much better.
That's a,
that's a very,
it's a scary way to think of it,
but I don't think we
talk about that enough.
Okay.